as stated simple harmonic motion
it talks about any kind of oscillating
system a system that goes
back and forth and back and forth a
spring
is a classic example literally a classic
example
um it's not the only one though this is
moving up and down
another up and down oscillating system
might be say
the tides as they come in and out and
they move boats up and down
you don't just have to have up down
oscillating systems you could have
left right oscillating systems like say
a pendulum
would be a good example it goes back and
forth and back
and forth now when you have a look at
the motion of it
and particularly as you watch that
purple thing moving up and down and up
and down what kind of function jumps out
at you to represent
this motion as according to what's being
tracked there what do you see
that looks like a sine wave to me right
in fact i'll go one better than a sine
wave
sine is short for sinusoidal
which is a big category of waves
um the cosine wave is also sinusoidal
has the same shape it just starts
and ends at a different spot so the
sinusoidal wave or a sinusoidal function
describes everything that works in an
oscillating
way but you can't just say oh it kind of
looks like that
right for example a trained expert would
have done this beforehand but i didn't
bring
i'm just going to break this a little
bit hold on
for example you can look at some things
in the real world
that you might think look like something
but they're actually
not so for instance if you take a string
or a chain or anything that you could
suspend
underneath i've really tangled myself
here well done mr wu
anything you can suspend under its own
weight so here's a cable here
right now superficially just forget
about the wiggles for when it's all
tangled right
superficially doesn't that look kind of
like a parabola kind of looks
parabola-esque
right except that it's not it's not a
parabola it's a different kind of shape
called a catenary
so you can't just like trust your eyes
and say oh it looks like a parabola
let's just make it a parabola
i know it looks like a sine wave it's a
very good guess
but can we do better than just guessing
take with me this idea of modeling
with a particular mathematical function
so i'm just going to go with say for
example
x for displacement and let's just choose
some particular
sine wave with
some unknown frequency so remember the
part of this that
is affected by frequency is going to be
within
the brackets here right it's going to be
the coefficient of
whatever our variable is normally we're
used to having like a y and an x in here
but i'm calling x my displacement and
this is relative to
time i guess so i'm going to pop a t
in there for time and my n is changing
whatever my frequency
is now this particular graph here
you can see it starts at the origin
that's just for the convenience of the
animation but doesn't have to
we could change the phase of it to
anywhere we like right we can just move
it left to right
have it begin at some arbitrary point
now what i want to show you is why from
again a mathematical standpoint not like
looking at the data
why this actually is going to work
perfectly for us
and actually the reason that's going to
make sense that this is actually
something i'm wearing weirdly enough
the tool that we use to understand
motion and change is
differentiation right i can integrate to
get out of this but i can differentiate
to go from displacement to what's the
next thing
velocity now i could call that v but for
reasons of convention i'm going to go
with one of the other ways of
representing
uh velocity which is x with a dot above
it which is differentiating with respect
to time
okay you can tell me what the derivative
is sine of nt plus alpha what are you
going to get
simple chain rule right do the inside
and and then i differentiate the outside
it's sine so it turns into
cos and then everything else comes along
for the right
so far so good so this is a velocity
equation that i have here
i'm going to go one more and then this
will show me why this is so perfect
for simple harmonic motion when i go to
the next derivative
down to acceleration hear me what am i
going to get
on the next line
okay so you're doing a couple of things
at the same time right so you've
helpfully excuse me pop the minus sign
out the front
anticipating this cause is going to
differentiate into negative
sine at the same time you've recognized
that m is already there but it will get
another n because of
the inside derivative right so that
gives you an m squared
and then everything else comes along for
the ride
yes now the reason why this is important
is if you have a look just right here
this is the displacement function we
began with is it not
so therefore what i can do is i can say
of this
acceleration equation i can go from just
happy old derivatives these are
derivatives here to
something which relates the original
function with its
derivative do you we have a name from
this do you remember what this is called
from extension one
this is called a differential equation
it's an equation
that relates an original function with
one of its derivatives in this case it's
second order because we differentiate
twice okay
now look at this carefully all right
this is the magical part that tells us
why
this is perfect for simple harmonic
motion right
i said i was wearing my illustration one
of the best
models for simple harmonic motion is a
rubber band
okay because if you can imagine let's
use my um let's use my left hand as the
center of motion okay if you can imagine
trying to move
with my right hand this is like a
particle something like that further
away right
don't worry i'm not going to break it i
have self-interest so i'm not going to
do this just to hurt myself okay
as i move further you can even see it
can't you right um
because i'm i've so little upper body
strength right i i can't move
past a certain limit because what's the
rubber band doing to me
it's resisting me going further another
way of saying it's resisting me from
going further
is it's trying to restore me back in the
opposite direction
right and at some point i go across the
other way
and then once i come on the this is your
right hand side right on my right on
your right hand side i'm being moved
back towards the
left and once i get to this left hand
side i'm being moved back towards the
right now do you see what's going on
here and how this is related
to the equation the differential
equation we've just
written down look right here
do you see this this is what we call a
restoring force
because what it's doing is it
sending you back toward in this case the
center of motion
right if your displacement is some
positive value towards the right
then the acceleration will be towards
the left
in the opposite direction if your
displacement is towards the left
then this negative is going to send you
back towards the right that's the way
the acceleration will work
so the acceleration
always opposes
the displacement in terms of
the direction the sign and that's what
locks you in you can see
the further you get away the more it
pushes you back just like that rubber
band was sending me
more forcefully back towards the center
of motion the further i pulled it does
that make sense
now uh the last thing that i wanted to
show you quickly here
if i showed you yeah no that's what i
wanted last thing i need to show you
quickly here
is the help that you get
to uh remember all this stuff right so
reference sheet
right page one some boring stuff that
you don't really
need to worry too much about page two
starts to get interesting page three
you've spent a whole bunch of time
recently and then
you get to that very special page right
at the end right and then lo and behold
in that final section there it's even
called mechanics
right now just have a look have a look
one two three lines right at the bottom
there okay what do you notice well the
first thing is
you've got these two different ways of
stating a sinusoidal
wave you can do cos you can do sine
we're going to look in a minute as to
why you might choose one
versus the other and then lastly you'll
notice a tiny little
modification actually to what
differential equation i've written
versus the differential equation they've
written
compare what i've got written or what
you've got written with what's in here
what's the difference
yeah this is extra constant there right
plus c now it's um
easy to believe oh it's just plus c like
any constant of integration but it's
actually not
just for constant of integration it's
actually
for a center of motion
think about this right if you just start
with this vanilla old sine function
right let me just go back to that uh
animation from before
okay the center of motion here is around
the origin
right it's around zero you can go up to
like one and then down to negative one
right but maybe your motion doesn't move
around zero
maybe it actually is much higher or
maybe it's much deeper
right if you had like a submarine that
was going up and down but underneath
like subterranean okay so therefore all
i need to do is just introduce a
vertical shift into this right
but think about what happens as soon as
you do the first derivative what happens
to that plus c
it's gone right because it's a constant
and then when you do the second
derivative well that constant was
already gone right
so when you get to this point here this
is no
longer the original displacement
function
is it it's the displacement function
without that constant which is the
center of motion so instead of
substituting in just
x at this point i'd have to substitute
in oops sorry i got rid of it
you'd have to substitute in x minus
c because the c is not there anymore
down this line does that make sense
so all that's you're looking at here is
like a more generalized version
of this which is kind of like the
classic version of it make sense